welcome to this video playing he hot 45
he would fortify from Israel so r we
yeah maybe play this difference Steinitz
again played this a number of times in
Switzerland got quite decent positions
very similar positions to compare to to
a normal and all the rebut with a bit of
a twist like here we're quick on
fianchetto is try to accomplish should
be should be okay now g5 is not a big
deal okay
of course i'd like to play Knight a5 and
c5 but at the moment after Knight a5 he
might just take a five maybe you know
okay maybe just start with arrow p895
does not look really dangerous I mean
even rookie seven should be okay okay
yeah maybe he can play d5 now something
I mean I'm not quite sure what 95 is all
about he cannot really take on f7 or get
anything tactical going wow really I
have to age 6 what what exactly is the
point okay yeah I'm going to play that
anyway I mean no use in spending time
this is just winning two pieces against
against the rook I think or what exactly
is the point I mean Knight f6 now and
night xe5 now I mean f4 I really really
don't get it
yeah he forget yeah okay I was about to
say if I get in 27 Bishop e6 Latin I
mean he needs to take at some point and
he decided to take now yeah this is just
um just a nice position ok maybe go here
and taking a find I know he's got this
check actually it was stupid ok I want
to get the Queen's off anyway so let's
do that ok he does not have any direct
way forward him i would like to keep
keep rocks on hmm
okay just look here proly here to
prevent rock the edge Bishop fa to e7 is
a good good plan and then maybe night be
64 this kind of regrouping this kind of
removing you know what would you six
actually why not yeah I thought g4 would
be good here with Knight f6 coming okay
let's not waste lots of time it looks
like the right move anyway and now
Knight f6 on taking on a three maybe
take you first it's more that's more
forcing 95 or night 96
might have six prolly just blocking
their file that might be useful so let
me go here
yeah I think he probably needs to you
have to play that cover cavity phone
okay
want to get rook rook to the F also
check okay if I go Bishop takes there is
Bishop f3 and Bishop f5 threatened it
looks very promising actually now that's
very nice now Bishop f5 check Bishop f3
check both are very year tough to meet
especially as all of those pieces here
hold light squares at G for two or three
I don't really see a move to be honest
hmm yeah there's no move now here can
shake and play rock DJ check the check
and push up a fade check let's see now
Bishop fa de risk that something easier
Bishop f8 is very strong now it does not
have any meaningful checker or anything
I'm just threatening look aged 60 Bishop
takes our age 6 okay if I take it with
the rook looking g5 yeah check on g6
King h5 there is no new memories no
direct made funny enough ok I can I can
just cover your 5 it's probably easiest
oh yeah Knight f6 and king g5 Pusha page
six check made now check that's the
easiest white resigns yeah I mean Bishop
takes f7 or what what this whatever this
this capture on f7 it's simply not
working I made a mistake though I really
made a mistake if you look at this here
and takes check in here in this position
this moves this move is of course are
just just terrible you can play queen
bee three and aunt is winning Jack I
have to I have no square simply to put
the king bishop c6 was a total how low I
need to play a big weenie seven or this
move after that it's just like the game
it's a very very good for like this CA
could have played instead of f3 queen
bee three and once I mean I'm running
right into this year check just terrible
yeah after he missed this chance we get
this this end game type of position
where black is just just clearly better
ya hear this g4 so is very young yeah
it's very logical and I guess probably
winning as like is getting all this all
the attacking play against the the pawns
and even an attack against the king is
is looming so yeah this was a bit lucky
I just played this movie I just played
this far too quickly for some reason it
does not show her at the time here to
know what has a CEO is doing but this is
of course a big London he could have
played queen bee three if I avoid that
there should be two be clearly better
like it happened in the game okay thanks
for watching